this is a story that sounds not like a
news story but only like a parody that
we would expect to see on Saturday Night
Live but it appears to be all too real
Donald Trump reportedly gave German
Chancellor Angela Merkel a bill for 300
billion British pounds the equivalent of
three hundred and seventy eight billion
u.s. dollars when they recently met to
cover contributions that Trump believes
are owed to NATO by Germany we've talked
about the prior embarrassment that we
knew about from Donald Trump's absurd
meeting with the German Chancellor where
he referred to the United States as a
company refused to shake Angela Merkel's
hand during a press photography moment
in the Oval Office called a German media
outlet fake news without evidence and we
now have learned that he did something
even more outrageous Donald Trump made
the demand for 300 billion British
pounds during private talks when they
met in Washington DC is being reported
by The Sunday Times there's a German
minister who's describing the reported
move by Donald as quote outrageous and I
have to agree with that now if you're
wondering what David what is this even
about a bill to money to NATO what are
you talking about NATO countries pledged
three years ago to spend two percent of
their GDP on defense and only a few
countries are actually doing that right
the UK Greece Poland in Estonia the sum
being demanded by Trump is basically
back dating to 2002
the year that Angela Merkel's
predecessor pledged to spend more money
on defense and Trump reportedly urged
his aides to calculate how much Germany
how much German spending fell below two
percent over the last 12 years and then
added interest Donald Trump also tweeted
about this sort of indirectly saying
despite what you have heard from the
fake news I had a great meeting with
German Chancellor Angela Merkel
nevertheless Germany Oh
vast sums of money to NATO and the
United States must be paid more for the
powerful and very expensive defense it
provides to Germany now Evo dollar who's
the former US ambassador to NATO
responded on Twitter explaining that
chunk basically doesn't understand
anything he sent out a tweet shortly
after this saying sorry mr. president
that's not how NATO works the u.s.
decides for itself how much it
contributes to defending NATO and going
on to say this is not a financial
transaction you can see a second tweet
at the bottom of the screen this is not
a financial transaction where NATO
countries pay the u.s. to defend them
it's part of our treaty commitment the
unnamed German minister who commented on
this also added quote the concept behind
putting out such demand is to intimidate
the other side but the Chancellor took
it calmly and will not respond to such
provocation Pat what I would give to be
a fly on the wall when Trump is
directing someone to do this can you
imagine the conversation some aide walks
into the Oval Office Trump says hey can
you print out an invoice to Germany for
NATO contributions a mr. president you
mean like go to accounting and have them
formally invoice no no just a fake
invoice it should just look like an
invoice and I'm going to hand it to her
a fake invoice mr. president yes but for
NATO contributions to Germany mr.
president yes and and what should it say
just three hundred billion pounds so
from the US perspective I think this
just kind of comes across as an
embarrassment but if you look at the
more German perspective I think this is
kind of reminiscent of the Treaty of
Versailles which essentially blamed the
costs of World War one on the German
people and they had to pay I think up to
like 500 billion dollars in today's
money and reparations so I mean to place
all the blame on them for these back
payments that they owe to NATO it really
just shows a lack of perspective in
German history yeah I would bet that
Donald Trump is not familiar with the
ins and outs of the Treaty of Versailles
and right so so just Germany may be
aware of situations where historically
they've actually had to pay
for certain things and a fake invoice
from Trump is not exactly going to cast
the fear that maybe Trump wanted on
Angela Merkel I'm just saying I think
it's important to look through the eyes
of a German citizen when you make these
move why does no one in the Oval Office
just put their foot down and say Donny
Boyd this is a bad bad idea we're not
doing it former Secretary of Labor under
Bill Clinton Robert Reich said Trump is
an international embarrassment to use
the term that Patras use to our allies
around the world he doesn't represent
most Americans and we're doing all we
can
this made me cringe I mean a fake
invoice to the German Chancellor for
NATO spending I actually like that
Angela Merkel is just ignoring it and
not even taking it seriously that's
unfortunately for the u.s. a growing
attitude of foreign leaders in diplomat
diplomats which is basically just acting
as if Trump is a little kid and ignoring
him completely the risk though Pat is
that when you ignore megalomaniacs they
will do unhinge things to get attention
and Trump does have access to the
nuclear launch codes that's my concern
Trump should be ignored but you got to
be careful when you ignore the
megalomaniac that's always a concern and
remember I mean Trump as a businessman
was considered kind of as a con man yeah
Trump University first and foremost so I
think he was just used to be able to get
away with this I like that Trump was
kind of considered a con man yes Trump
was a total and absolute con man and
many of the deals he claims to have
negotiated he didn't actually negotiate
himself so just cringe-worthy truly
cringe-worthy embarrassment